yeah i won the event 2017. i mean magnus
plays there every year i think he only
missed
the 2000 what year did he miss 2000
i think magnusian playing y can say in
2014 but other than that he's been there
okay now it's a time for the king's
gambit thank you bishop 23
for letting me play the queen's gambit
which is not a very good opening
and i have no idea how to play this with
white um
at least g5 gives me a target i mostly
play d5
against the king's gambit
let's see uh let's see if i can play the
king's gambit correctly
he plays h6 uh what do i play now
let's develop with knight c3 and if he
plays knight c6 he's threatening bishop
g4
and uh hmm
okay let's play h4 bishop g4 i have
knight e2
okay knight g7 seems like uh
hmm
okay i have absolutely no clue how to
play the king's gambit whatsoever
yeah in fact white could very well just
be lost in this position
hi wesley love from canada thanks for
keeping filipinos in the spotlight
yeah thank you shout out to all the
filipinos to all my
friends and fans out there um
yeah definitely uh thanks for watching
my games
let's see if i can find an interesting
question what does the 2700l know
that the 2600 doesn't
hi a good question what does what's the
difference about 2600 to a 2700 player
um okay let me i'm getting busted here
uh knight h2 is no good bishop f4 is no
good
i'll just play c3 i could lose this game
well the difference of between 700 and
2600
is it's really just consistency
so 2700 players are more consistent
they're also more accurate
um
they have better technique generally but
it's
it's it's basically experience
the differences experience consistency
and
technique i'm just a piece down
this is bad i should have played queen
e3
okay let's just try to play fast
and maybe we can uh
attack him on the time yeah but
difference between 700 2600
mostly consistency and
technique um
yeah this is bad
okay you have d5 ed
hmm yeah whatever i don't really care
about ratings
so if i lose this game that's fine
can you speak tagalog at least once i
would love to hear you speaking
our language yeah i'll try i actually
watch
roderick navas streams from time to time
videos so uh
uh he speaks very well okay
oh he has a draw yeah
if he takes the draw that's fine
i mean of course he should play on
because he's a couple of pawns up
and then roderick nava talks like they
would say
um maraming salamat post
[Music]
24